Bren Stark is the night King that's the
theory that has been floating around for
quite some time among Game of Thrones
fans this theory might have been
confirmed by the season 7 finale but
I'll catch up with you about that a bit
later in this video but is there also
comes the theory in which John Snow
would have to kill the last male heir of
House Stark so let's just jump into it
throughout the seven seasons Game of
Thrones proved the time shell theory
that states whatever happens happens
true in the words of the three-eyed
Raven the past is already written the
ink is dry brain is always going to
travel back in time causing young Willis
to become Holder if we accept this then
we also must accept a fact that anything
bran does during his time travels is not
only always going to happen but they
will have a direct effect in shaping the
future however bran stark on the other
hand has not fully accepted all many
lessons the three-eyed Raven had told
him bran highlighted numerous times
during the season seven that he has to
learn to see better so he could be read
even the long night comes again he is
aware that his abilities are going to be
of the great importance now that the
Great War has arrived but it's his
naivety of being able to change the past
that could ultimately caused him to
become the night king during one of his
time travels basically bran will believe
that he can rewrite history so he would
travel back multiple times only to end
up fulfilling his own fate Brandon
firstly shell back several decades to
prepare the Seven Kingdoms for the Great
War he would whisper into the mad Kings
ear to prepare wildfire for the incoming
hoard of the army of the dead before I
go any further let me remind you that
during one vision in season six Brent
called out to his father in desperation
and to his shock Ned heard him but
dismissed it as there was no one to see
the three-eyed raven pulled bran out of
the vision and reprimanded him again for
trying to interact with the past this
pretty much supports this part of a
theory in which brain will try to warn
the current ruler of the Seven Kingdoms
that the dead are coming by whispering
into his ear however not only that his
brains attempt would fail but he would
also realize that it was in fact him and
his whisperers the Joe Aerys Targaryen
to madness the reason why ears kept
repeating the phrase burned mo who
turned out to be because of brand
traveling back and trying to warn him of
the approaching army of the Dead
instead whispers only heightened dares
is already uncontrollable paranoia
leading him to burn alive
many innocent people including Nets
fodder and nets older brother before
introduced with brands second attempt to
save the mankind that would result with
him becoming the biggest threat to it
let me remind you of one fact even
though he's the three-eyed Raven brain
still does not know everything that has
happened throughout the history as it
has been proven numerous times perhaps
an actor that plays bran explaining the
best he said the way it works at the
moment is that he's basically got the
Kindle library of the whole history of
the universe he just hasn't read every
book yet and the old three eyed Raven
has set in that tree for thousands of
years and read her every piece of
history and has accessed it all for now
he needs people like Sam to tell him
what they want him to see
anyways despite failing two times bran
will still believe that he can somehow
change the past and stop the night king
which is when he actually would become
the night king himself
Brens second and final attempt to change
the past takes him when the night king
was created brain works into the human
that later is going to become the night
king to try to warn and convince the
children of the forest not to turn him
into the first of the white walkers bran
doesn't realize that the past has
already been written and he also does
not realize that the children of the
forest will not recognize him nor
believing his words this is an brain
realizes that he failed again so he
tries to go back in the current timeline
but cannot because he is too deep and
has stayed too long in the past the old
three-eyed Raven did warn him about us
and perhaps foreshadow brains horrible
fate multiple times he said I've told
you many times stay too long where you
don't belong and you will never return
the three-eyed Raven also said it is
beautiful beneath the sea but if you
stay too long you'll drown so basically
brain tries to stop the children of the
forest from creating the white Walker
leader but instead gets trapped inside
the knight Kings body since he has
stayed too long to live back into the
present day
hence bran equals the supreme leader of
White Walkers in further convincing
evidence bran and the knight king pretty
much dress exactly the same many are
also claiming that the season 7 finale
might have even provided more evidence
to support the popular theory in case
you have not noticed once the wall
crumbled the knight king's army
proceeded to march south in the shape of
a direwolf the stark sigil when viewed
from above leading many to believe in
bran stark equals the night king theory
if this proves to be true it would also
fulfill the bittersweet ending promised
by george RR martin in order to end the
long night
to defeat the army of the Dead Jon Snow
would have to kill the last male heir of
how stark bran and that the only reason
the Lord of Light raised John from death
and as always let me know your opinion
about all of this in the comment section
down below I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace